Oh, hold on.
I think the audio is all weird.
Give me a second.
Oh!
Let me try this.
Wait.
No.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Hold on.
Give me a second.
Can you hear it twice?
Is it okay?
Give us this song.
Only once?
Okay.
Every different, every little thing has a different sound.
Say start game has a sound.
Load game has a sound.
Options has a sound.
.
Scourge, it's your birthday!
I got some pizza, can you cast a spell on it to make it
taste super delicious?
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Moe!
Kiyun!
Happy birthday!
Scourge!
Three months already?
We're at three months!
Holy cow.
Also, let me know if it's too loud.
Wait, is it?
I can't tell which one you're hearing.
So I'm gonna put it here.
I can't tell.
Ah!
It's a bit loud.
It's okay, but can be lower.
Is it louder?
Is it okay now?
Three month gang!
So we are!
Yippee!
Three months!
Oh my goodness.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Welcome to Eternal Darkness.
Sanity is Requiem.
Spooky Game for Spooky Ghost.
This is a game I have always wanted to play.
I feel like I've always seen it like, you know, back in the
day.
I always used to see it at the store.
Like, the game store and be like, oh my god.
does someone recommend this because you like metal gear
solid it's the same company that did twin snakes right um
but yeah i would always see it at the store and i've always
been a fan of horror so i was like i've got to play it but i
never had a game cube until metal gear yeah silicon night
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you for all the
memberships you guys much actually tomorrow will be a
membership stream so uh yippee it all comes back to metal
gear pretty much so i know like nothing about this game i
know a little bit about like there's a sanity meter and
that's all i know oh and i also know apparently you need to
play the game three times which i don't know what's up with
that we'll see what's going on before we get to that point.
Love this game.
It's great to watch you play.
I can't wait to lose my sanity.
Yeah!
It's my second favorite GameCube game behind Fire Emblem.
Wow.
Yeah, I really just wanted to I really just wanted to play
something that I hadn't seen people really playing.
So I was just like, well, this has been on my list.
No better time than the present.
If I don't play it now, I'll just keep putting it off, you
know?
So, hmm.
Wait, you have No, I have no sanity left.
Supra!
Supra Limitol!
Thanks for the 10 gift and thank you!
Check off MGS.
Vengeance on your Pringo card.
Shut up!
TP Table Trade, thank you for the 10 gift and thank you!
Yeah, I have no sanity.
I hope you guys don't either.
We're all in this together, right?
Start the game!
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
That's a voice?
Oh!
Oh.
What do?
Oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
But I need that.
Um.
Just play it one sitting, obviously.
Oh, I'm looking at my...
Okay, speedrun, baby.
We're just gonna go without saving.
Santo Pici, Santo Pici.
Wait, you know what?
Okay, I will figure this out later.
I will figure this out later.
No way.
Hardy horn?
Flesh.
Bone.
Bound together with the oddest magical incantation.
This wretched book is where it all began so long ago.
before time before humanity I am dr. Edward Royvis I am a
clinical psychologist oh I am also dead what this is not my
story okay even the story of the Royvis family why are you
here it is the story of humanity oh Nintendo or not believe
it or not as you will your perceptions will not change
reality but simply color Humanity has been on the edge of
extinction for two millennia what for that long so much and
dependent on so few The guardians grow restless.
I have another thing why I've decided to play this once
again near again That's on the flesh My family has crossed
their path and they didn't take kindly to it Their attention
turns to my granddaughter For she is the last of my line.
And the last hope for humanity.
Oh, yeah.
She looks like Tomb Raider.
Oh, she's better now.
Oh, my God.
She's got a gun.
Oh, there's a skeleton.
There's a skilly man all in my room.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
Please shoot the gun.
Shoot the gun.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
Ouch!
Is this what happens when your sanity is low?
Shoot the gun!
Oh!
Nice!
Nice, nice!
Oh my god.
They're immortal because they're skeleton.
May the rats eat your eyes!
Who is- what is happening?!
Grandpa!
Oh, is that all just a- dream oh 3 33 a.m let's go the the
witching hour hello hello miss Alexandria Roybus um yeah
who's this this is inspector LaGrasse of the Rhode Island
police I'm sorry to disturb you but there's been an accident
with your grandfather I'll be on the next flight out oh okay
the Royvis family estates Rhode Island oh my god gumshoe ah
miss Royvis I'm pleased to know her eyes you had a pleasant
trip I mean oh my god my condolences this is most unpleasant
it's a shame we couldn't meet under brighter circumstances
yes it is can we get this over with please?
Oh, yeah, straight to the point.
But I must warn you, it's not a pleasant sight.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm prepared.
I'm prepared for anything.
I'm afraid there's not much to see.
What do you mean?
Is he dust?
What happened?
Is he, like, atomized?
What happened to his body?
Oh!
What do you mean there's not much to see?
What was going?
What do you mean?
Is that your grandfather, Edward?
Oh my god!
Yes, it's him.
He just slipped into jelly.
Not much to see.
That was like the whole body, man.
I don't understand.
Why are you showing me this?
Did he just smirk?
Can't you check dental records or something?
What is wrong with you?
I'm... I'm sorry.
You're the one... It's my job, lady.
You're the only living relative.
And no, we can't check dental records.
You were the one who said...
There's no head!
There's no sign of intrusion and there was certainly a lot
of force used here.
I have never seen anything like this in my 20 years on the
force.
We have no evidence except for the body.
And what's left doesn't say much.
We don't have a single clue.
Well, you better find out who did this.
Yeah.
I'm not leaving Rhode Island until you do.
There must be some clue in this old mansion revealing what
happened.
answers.
So do I.
How could she tell if there's no head?
He was had the ring on, apparently.
Two weeks later!
Oh,
shocked by her grandfather's mysterious death and frustrated
at the incompetence of the local police, Alex vows to
uncover the truth.
She decides to search the mansion, the place where Edward
conducted his research.
if there was a tie to his past it possibly and possibly a
tie to his murderer it would be here
um what was i gonna say oh another reason i decided to play
this was because like the day i was trying to decide what to
play um nintendo put out like a oh a video did you guys see
like the emio thing which is a it was like hinting at at
like a horror game that it they're working on and I was like
I was like you know I think I think Nintendo like has I'm
talking here excuse me um I think they have like the
copyright to the sanity system in this so I was like what if
they kind of like incorporate it but now I think it's
blooper team and I'm really disappointed oh my god what is
going on I don't have a flashlight okay this is combat I'm
combat I have the I have the slowest punch in the west.
What's this one?
Nothing.
Okay.
How do I... Oh, I can just punch normal.
Okay, this is block then.
Alright.
Nice clock.
I'm examining it.
Okay.
Is that grandpa?
Grandpa!
Oh!
Portraits of the Ancestral Royvis line the the foyer wall
line the foyer walls wait so it's not it's not the Royvis
line is the
portraits of the ancestral and sorry I have to really
emphasize the annocestral Royvis line the foyer walls their
faces reveal a dark brooding edge there is something about
each one that gives the viewer an unsettling feeling.
I feel very unsettled right now.
Wait, can I check the clock again then?
Oh, here we go.
A beautiful carriage clock.
The hands appear to be...
Nintendo sits on cool horror games like Fatal Frame.
Fatal Frame!
But, you know, we still have these classics at least.
Just a membership.
The hands appear to be stuck, yet the clock continues to
tick with the The time permanently set to 3.33.
There's a key in the back of the clock, presumably for
winding it.
Oh!
Should Alex look at the key?
Yes!
Oh!
Alex picks up the desk clock and pulls the key from it.
However, there's something odd about the key.
It isn't for winding it at all.
It looks like a dresser key!
Oh!
Ghosts are so rude.
Stop the voices.
I wish I could run.
Oh, here's another Roy V.
a slime.
I hear birds.
Bum bum.
Examine.
Oh.
I'm trapped.
The last week rays of sunlight fight the shroud of darkness.
It lends an eerie field to the last few weeks' events.
As the sun sets, Alex will be alone in this house with
nothing but the spirits of old for company.
This is the original Luigi's mansion.
Wait, where?
They didn't solve anything, though.
The call of the mansion beckons to Alex, drawing her back to
uncover the family secrets it hides.
Alex will not leave till she has learned what happened to
her grandfather.
I did not expect, like, a visual novel going on here.
It's beautiful, though.
Okay.
What's this way?
Open door.
Oh my god.
God, it's scary.
What is this?
Grandpa?
A wooden plaque is fastened to the door taking the place of
the lock.
A colored sigil is carved into the wood above a wide slot.
The slot is just wide enough to insert a narrow blade?
What is going on in this place?
Whoa, they even have the lens flare.
Is this the kitchen?
What?
Grandpa can't.
Can I get a snack?
No?
Nothing around here.
Okay.
Interesting.
Hold left trigger.
Oh!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Grandpa.
Oh.
Grandpa, can you play?
The grand piano stands here, awaiting the hands of a decent
musician.
Unfortunately, Edward never really lived up to that
description.
And as such, the piano fell into disuse.
Sky, thanks for the time, gifted.
Thank you.
Come on.
Oh, what's this?
Nothing?
Oh, she's got them Barbie heels.
They sound so good.
What is this?
Oh.
Fascinating.
What is that up there, though?
Yeah, these.
The illustration features a collection of strange line
designs related to each other in a...
cyclical manner there appears to be some significance to it
but there isn't particularly but it isn't particularly
evident okay
which was over here i didn't go through this door where did
grandpa die at in here this looks like he where he died oh
my god i'm scared don't do that to me game oh what's nothing
here okay Grandpa?
Grandpa?
Oh my god.
Another person.
Another clock.
Hickory dickory dock.
This looming grandfather clock seems to stand ominously.
Katsu, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Ominously in the corner, gazing on this empty room with an
almost patriarchal air.
Huh?
Use this and left and right to adjust the clock hands.
I'm not gonna adjust him right now.
Thank you!
I've been waiting for a VTuber to play Eternal Darkness.
Thanks.
Irish.
Restwacha.
Okay.
So far, only a little scary.
Where did...
Why does Grandpa have such a huge house?
Wait, which way did we come through?
What's in here?
Oh.
Then what was the other one?
Here, here, here.
What?
What is this?
A brass-framed mirror is set onto the wall.
The mirror's direction can be adjusted by the means of two
crankshafts set below it.
Bangor after bangor after bangor games.
Thanks, Zachary.
A curious device.
Is it related to the telescope in some way?
Should it add?
that's not adjusted just yet why is there a globe in the
ground um a globe cradled in a wooden frame there's so much
there's so much stuff you know this house has some fun stuff
in it i know right it's glossy surfaces this is probably how
grandpa died he tripped over this globe in the ground it's
glossy surfaces painted in the likeness of an ancient map a
lens is situated in the northern hemisphere above a label
that reads, there be dragons here.
Dragons!
Hmm.
I feel like a dragon would be a pain in my side.
Okay, this is the same thing that adjusts.
Wait, so there's two of them.
Okay.
How do I look through it?
I don't think it would let me, but... Oh, wait.
Maybe?
Here?
What is that?
Oh!
okay cool so there's three of them wait huh I guess we're
gonna start cranking it
never mind we'll come back crank that soldier boy Superman
now whoa watch me you watch me you oh it's locked we have a
we have a dresser key oh my God, sorry, the voices sometimes
I just don't expect of.
They spook me really bad.
Lighty.
Santa Claus.
I don't know if Santa was in our lineage.
Oh, do I have a...
It's locked.
I think I have a...
What's the word?
A...
I don't hear any voices.
Wait, you guys don't hear the voices?
You guys are hearing the music though, right?
Right?
You don't hear the whispers?
The...
They only happen sometimes.
Huh?
I guess we will start cranking it.
Anything you say, boss, you heard that...
What does that mean?
What did I say weird?
Take your meds.
Huh?
You haven't heard the...
All I hear is boombo...
They happen sometimes.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you when it happens.
But yeah, we need to find the dresser.
I think.
I guess.
I also don't know how to use my inventory.
I hear the whispers.
You do?
Wait, and we also need a soul.
There, there, there!
You heard that?
You heard it?
Care to demonstrate?
Just like that.
Okay, you guys are just gaslighting me.
You guys scare me.
Like that, like that.
Right there, right there.
Dresser key.
We need to find the dresser.
It's a euphemism for self-love.
Of course.
It's not a day until I say something that I don't know what
it means.
Oh, okay.
Let's go back to the...
Alright, so there is the grandfather clock.
Down this way.
I don't think you know a gaslight.
lighting is.
What?
What are you talking about?
I basically invented the, I coined the phrase.
Am I supposed to be seeing something here?
Hmm.
Over here?
Anything?
What I was trying to say earlier is I think I have a stamina
meter.
Because she was like, she was like heavy breathing after I
was running a lot.
So here.
Oh.
Yes.
What if we move it to 333?
Uh...
I knew it!
Okay.
This is, uh...
Oof.
Doing some...
They're still working on the renovations, you know?
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa, I like the Blinky Book.
Whoa.
Candles.
There's a spooky ghost in the bottom left corner.
In the left corner!
I don't think there should be a ghost in the left corner.
Oh, we got the dagger.
Uh.
An ancient Roman weapon, a Gladius, is on display above the
fireplace mantle.
Another token of eclectic junk.
Pick it up.
Oh
my gosh, I was close!
Each one cemented into place.
What twisted psyche could have executed this drawing?
Though disturbing, it is meticulously rendered down to the
subtlest detail.
The precise anatomy of fractured bones and the convolutions
of spines and ribs entwined into a mesmerizing sight.
English is my second language.
I first speak ghost.
A painting of a jungle shrouded building.
It seems to be a temple in Asia, perhaps from Thailand or
Cambodia.
This is a bizarre drawing of a cyclopean city.
Say something in ghost.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
They're insulting me, but you guys wouldn't understand, you
know?
If you guys ever get a spirit box, ask, what are you eating?
And I'll be like, hungry for spaghetti.
It's immense architecture bathed in an unnatural fog.
The detail is incredible.
As Alex studies it, she can almost imagine the city's
inhabitants.
Okay, I think we have more things to worry about, Alex.
I think we've got more things to worry about.
This looks like some kind of mask.
The face is serene and composure.
That's what you call serene?
We don't speak zoinks.
A serene and composure with a faint hint of a smile tugging
at the corners of the mouth and eyes closed in deep
meditation.
This is serene?
I don't know.
Maybe I've never felt peace.
This Gothic cathedral is silhouetted against a stark light.
The image is vicious and devoid of subtlety.
Every brushstroke echoes the spikes of the architecture,
imbuing a violent feeling as though the building itself is a
harsh imposition on reality.
A grim picture indeed.
It's a house!
yo it ain't that deep it ain't just a house can't really see
the cathedral me neither it was so dark serene bro looks
like he's pogging is that right what's this an aged page set
inside a glass frame hangs on the wall an insane scribbling
covers the page incomprehensible to Alex perhaps if Alex had
some kind of tome it could be deciphered is that what this
is for a large leather-bound antique book rests upon the
cluttered desk we shall read it done done oh now it's bright
in here what
the dune the popcorn
i had no knowledge of what was to come the popcorn bucket
nor did i care how the knowledge changed me it will also
change you as you read this you will come to learn as I
have.
You too will come to understand or you will perish.
Ooh.
Grandpa, maybe you should have locked this up.
You think that once I could not see beyond the veil of our
reality.
A chosen one.
To see those who dwell behind.
My life now has purpose.
For I have learned the frailty of flesh and bone.
Flesh and bone, flesh and bone!
Yo, why are we in Rome?
What's happening?
What?
What just happened?
Our enemies did not have a chance.
why did they switch do you believe that it really exists
centurion I do not doubt our Emperor's beliefs or his orders
but if we are to retrieve the artifact we must be strong
Latin budget right now I suddenly know Latin yeah we all
have become wiser today
why you suck us dust well wait he it so quickly no augustus
no don't listen to the voices why why is he walking like
that my guy is struggling pious augustus oh my gosh sick
thank you brother silver john thank you so much
oh come to us pious augustus Such a fun name to say...
What is going on?
Oh my god, Stonehenge!
Ah!
What is happening?
Oh my god, he went to the nether.
I'm pious!
I got stuns!
Oh no!
Oh my god.
The dyes on the floor is finally crafted.
Inlaid with gold and gems that can't identify.
A strong linear design is situated in the middle and is
equally unknown to the Roman soldier.
Ampius Augustus.
What is that super chat?
One of my favorite games on the GameCube?
Oh, we got the thing.
Spooky game!
Thank you!
Thanks, Mr. Retired.
Okay, I don't think there's anything here.
Nothing here.
Except the spooky skulls.
Look at all the skulls.
Oh, yeah.
The shaft descends towards the next lower level.
A ladder is situated on one side of the shaft.
Okay.
Well, take it.
The ladder leads into the dank heart of the labyrinth.
Danger lurks beneath, yet Pius's courageous resolve does not
buckle.
Should Pius climb down the ladder?
Yeah!
Oh, uh-oh.
Climb up?
Oh my god.
Wait, can I see him first person?
Okay.
I think that guy is gonna stand up.
Plus my lottery luck?
Are you sure you want me to do that?
I'm going to die.
Jackpot!
Are you pressing triangle?
I'm pressing everything.
Oh, see?
I'm afraid of booby traps, but let's just walk.
I mean, run.
He's got a blinky thing.
Ah!
I knew they were going to get out!
Oh my god.
Are they all going to get out?
We'll just...
Ah!
Oh my god.
Don't hurt me!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Health meter.
Thank you.
Sudden tutorial.
Oh my gosh.
Mini scooter.
Welcome to Van Boucher.
Thank you.
This meter represents life energy.
Every time a character takes damage, the level will get
lower.
When it reaches zero, the character will die.
Okay.
This function allows the manipulation of inventory items
within the current room.
Allow the current character to radio weapon.
This function allows the examination of objects within the
inventory.
Press L or R allows switching back and forth between
sections within the interface.
How do I get out?
B?
Maybe?
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Turn around!
Turn around, Pius Augustus!
Pius, Pius, we're...
Pius, we need to run.
We're... we're...
Oh my gosh.
Pius, did I know there were three of you?
Oh my god.
Ouch!
There we go.
Nice, nice one.
Chop him up!
Don't let him walk again!
Oh, they're struggling.
Oh, nice!
Can I step out?
Oh, finish him!
Yeah!
What about these guys over here?
I'm walking so sad.
You guys not a problem?
Alright.
I'm gonna take this cube!
A strange granite block lies on the floor.
Alright.
It's my neck.
No!
Oh.
Baby Cor, thanks for the gift.
Happy birthday.
Wait, who?
Who's birthday?
Oh!
Lily!
Can I get happy birthday?
I just turned 30.
I can feel myself turning to dust.
You're just like the skeletons!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Dear Lily Breeze Happy birthday to you Skeleton
Nice It better not be anymore guys In the air
Oh Oh Ouch LJ Slice and dice Slice and dice Oh my god Run
away Oh my god Oh!
You!
Oh!
Finish him!
Nice.
I think I'm getting a hang of it.
Oh, I can finish this guy too.
I'm taking all your blocks!
You can't stop me!
This is how I learned how to read!
Strange granite block.
Pick it up.
Is this the same game?
I know, right?
Oh, ah!
Oh, God.
Uh-oh.
You guys?
Oh, God!
There's a lot of guys!
Pick up the block!
I think it's time to leave.
Did he just look at that, too?
Look at this.
Did we just react to the same thing?
Coward!
What are you talking about?
There's a skelly man right here.
Can I sneak?
Why can't I walk?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I can't see where I'm going.
This is kind of bad.
Ah!
Ouch!
Take his arm!
Take his body!
Take him!
Finish him!
I'm gonna go where he was going.
Oh, never mind.
Did they say Pius?
They're obsessed with me.
The bars across the door block Pius's exit from the room.
Is there another skelly over here?
Oh, okay.
I think I hear a skelly.
Oh my god, the angles, the camera angles are seriously
killing me right now.
Pius, I'm scared.
Pius!
Pius, I'm scared!
Run,
run, Pius, run, run Pius, run!
They're gone.
Oh, he's not gone.
Fifth attack, attack, attack!
Don't die, Pius!
Pius, you gotta live!
You gotta live!
Pius, you have to live!
Don't hit the wall, Pius, Pius!
Get one hit, in please pious just one hit what a pious pious
no finish him finish kill off that guy kill off that guy
kill off that guy okay pious is a change man he fears
nothing now
oh i don't have a purple one wait the purple one is my blade
oh just kidding um Who am I hearing?
Oh, I think I'm hearing the flames.
If I grab that, am I gonna...
Something gonna happen.
The wall is predominantly decorated with a strange symbol
carved into the granite.
Cut into the wall is a square hole lined with the scratches
as though something has been removed from it.
Facer cube fear.
I put all of them in, though, right?
hmm only two kids my parents wouldn't let me play this one
and dead and alive beach volleyball i was told they were
both just scared i think maybe dead or alive would cause a
scarier awakening than anything okay i think i just put them
all in all right let's grab the cube
women are pretty scary i'm not gonna lie Especially when
they're sexy.
Okay.
Time to put it in.
Wait.
It won't let me.
How do I get to the menu again?
How did I...
Oh, here.
Oh, okay.
Use.
Ah, just like that.
Okay.
Poor Mincer.
I'm scared of pretty girls.
You're not?
What if I put it in the wrong hole?
What if I, what if I, what if I put blue into red?
Wait, that was red, right?
Oh, thank goodness.
There's this really cute adorable ghost in the bottom right
of the screen.
Can you tell her that?
I don't know.
I don't know...
Here we go!
Avatar!
The last airbender!
Yippee!
Just run for it, Pius.
Pius Augustus.
Just run for it.
Don't let any Skellyman tell you otherwise.
Run!
Fuck!
That's me!
They really are obsessed with...
Wait, am I gonna have to fight myself?
What is going on?
Pius, you must prove your worth by destroying this statue.
Pressing R will enable Pius to select which target to
attack.
Releasing R slightly and then pressing it again will cycle
between multiple targets.
Pius can attack specific body parts while locked onto an
enemy by moving the stick and pressing A.
Use up to attack the head, left and right to attack the
arms.
Okay.
Oh.
Ah!
Hoah!
Yippee!
Okay.
I had to destroy myself.
I'm going...
I'm not leaving.
I'm going deeper in.
It's a ghost can't you tell skeletons to leave?
Probably.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I feel that I attack faster if I'm not...
If I'm not locked in though.
Oh my god.
Get him out!
Take him out!
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Pius don't die on it.
Pius!
Pius Augustus!
Pius Augustus, please!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Finish him.
Oh,
I think he's...
I think he's finished over.
There we go.
Pius!
Oh no, he's bleeding my bed!
What is this?
A button attached to a small pylon softly illuminates the
room.
A bizarre energy seems to radiate from it.
Push the button.
Hold on.
Oh my god, I can barely even run.
Yes, you're not gonna make it.
Why is there no way to defend myself?
He just needs to...
He just needs to rest for a second.
It's just so...
Tis a flesh wound.
Why is Augustus about to be Pius Augustus?
No!
What is this thing anyway?
Health?
No, then.
Push the button.
Is this gonna send me home?
Wait, this might send me home.
It looks kind of similar to the thing that we came here
with.
There we go.
Um...
Pius ain't looking so hot, you guys.
Oh, Pius looks like he's about to throw up.
Pius is...
Pius said, but it was beer o'clock.
Oh, do I pick one?
What's this?
Shaped like a delicate dome, a pale blue statuette floats
gracefully above the pedestal.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh, it's choose your starter Pokemon.
An effigy resembling a warped angel shaped from dark green
emerald hovers effortlessly above the pedestal.
A strange sculpture resembling a red-clawed worm.
Does it mysteriously flow above the pedestal?
Hmm, I think because I'm green.
I should pick green.
Also, I like the warped angel.
Pius Augustus, what powers do we grant upon?
on you.
Oh, you're okay.
He's seeing green.
No!
Pius!
Pius, a ghost doesn't know!
Eons have passed since then, and I have learned much.
I haven't learned anything.
I was once as naive as a child but now my mind is sharp with
the power of zealotath i can now read the thoughts of others
and make them raving mad with a mere suggestion face me and
you shall surely perish what guess tonight is it being green
tome of eternal darkness yippee
Can we read it now?
Strangely, with the Tome of Eternal Darkness in her
possession, Alex can read the page!
It is a chapter page from the Tome itself.
Yes.
The Binding of the Corpse God!
Zelotath turned Pius into an influencer.
What do you mean an influencer?
Yo!
Corpse God!
Oh, wait, I didn't read this before.
A small shrine of candles.
Their placement appears to be very deliberate, matching the
etchings on the table and the walls illustrations.
The candles are unlit.
Okay.
None of this is all...
None of this has changed, so...
I guess we can leave.
Oh, God.
It's so dark.
Even for me, it's hard to see.
Okay.
um oh gosh what am i what am i gonna have to fight i have
the slowest ever
if he was ever from vtuber syndrome ask your doctor of
zealotath is right for you okay so now that we solve the
grandfather clock and we have the tome oh wait we have the
dagger let's go do i think it was it was this way let's go
do the dagger will let us into the other room.
And here, I believe.
Oh, yeah.
I thought it was purple before.
Oh, do I need to use it?
That's it.
Oh, so now I have to address her key.
Second floor key!
When did I get that?
Underscale.
Thanks for three months!
It was purple before.
Alex places the blade in the slot but feels it push back.
It is as if the magic of the blade does not fit the lock.
All right.
Let's go to the second floor since I apparently got a second
floor key and I don't know when I got that.
The second or the key comes apart in the lock.
The key to the second floor is broken.
Perhaps there is a way of repairing it.
Oh.
Yippee!
Uh...
I was saying that there was TV table tray gifted to
memberships.
Thank you!
I think it's a little delayed, but thank you guys!
Yay, we got the broken key!
Yay!
Wait, how did they investigate this mansion?
How did they investigate the mansion if they didn't have
access to the second floor?
No wonder solve anything.
What if the murderer is in the... is right up there?
And we don't know about it.
Um, okay, maybe here.
Oh, I like this room.
It's nice and bright.
It's pretty.
It's so cool.
Wait, is this the dresser?
No way.
Oh, never mind.
Tizona, welcome to membership, I'm Bobboy, thanks for the
five gifted.
Thank you guys.
I don't know what I'm shifting here.
Like it doesn't...
I don't see anything moving.
Maybe I need to still wait on this one.
Oh, what was that?
Examine?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
In the warm glow of candlelight, the Royvis family tree
hangs from the wall.
Shadows flitter across its surface, obscuring the detail.
If one looks closely, the family's secrets are revealed.
Oh, oh my god, there's a dead man!
I saw the secret!
Is there anything on these shelves?
I didn't see anything.
Also, I noticed that she, like, does that thing in old games
where they like look at what you need to observe tax
fraud what am i examining oh the books in this corner seem
to focus on the supernatural the writings of po lovecraft
the poetry of blake the art of bosh everything with a tie to
ethereal horror or fantasy it is all here a reference
library to the arcane.
Was this Alex's grandfather's secret hobby?
My grandpa was a freak, let's go!
Was there anything that I couldn't read before?
Now I have my special tome, my special book.
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
I cannot say what was the true beginning, nor am I sure of
its end.
Oh!
So perhaps here is the best place to start.
Okay.
I am reminded of ideas I first encountered in Sir James
George Fraser's book, The Golden Bough, a study in magic and
religion.
We are overwhelmed by a very human need to weave a web of
meaning where there may be none.
Since time immemorial, ancient peoples have dressed up their
lack of knowledge as gods and demons.
You're calling them stupid?
I have discovered that sometimes the fates of gods and
mortals intertwine, and legends The golden bow bow.
Oh.
Thy time is done, great ancient.
Thy time.
Forever in shadow will you be master of chaos.
And to fade to nothing in obscurity will be thy fate.
My master has planned no millennia for this day.
It is the true chaos of all things that you now must be in
doubt.
tombed amongst the beings of flesh and bone oh you have a
great monument here Mount Turok it is a pity that no one
will ever recognize it that's our guy may the darkness claim
the crawling chaos and damn beast no longer will thy reign
be kept over the ancients you have kept imprisoned voice of
the fury the last of this world
he's voiced by the fury this guy pious augustus no way and
big bombs no don't hurt him
these mythical fables can keep me amused there has to be
something to do around here i only wish something that
fantastic and How your purpose could happen to me.
Oh, let's have it.
Let's let it happen.
Oh, uh-oh.
Um, the door just shut on its own.
Uh, the door is firmly closed.
Sailing the temple.
Perhaps there is another exit somewhere inside?
Uh-oh.
I have my weapon.
I'm a short sword.
Yeah, wish granted.
Good job, girl.
it this is also her cheek her singular cheek is out um the
statue of a goddess delicately sculpted from sandstone it
casts an alert eye over oh sorry everyone who enters the
temple there's a strained necklace around its neck should
elia take the necklace from the statue um
Hmm, I don't...
This game has tons of Metal Gear voice actors.
The girl you are now is Mei Ling?
Wait, I can hear it, though.
No, but yes.
Probably not, but sure.
Okay.
Strange necklace!
We're stealing from...
Uh-oh.
This necklace can be used to heal Elia.
Make sure that Elia does not move when the spell is being
taken.
cast oh we have health 10 times okay uh i can't see anything
it's so dark i'm just casually walking around this temple
whatever oh no i see them on the ground you guys look at all
of them they're all gonna come to life Oh, I hit the
cutscene.
What were you doing chilling in here that you didn't know
that they could...
That there were bodies in here too.
I'm just saying.
These guys are so gonna come to life.
Engraved on the floor is a striking design featuring the sun
sinking below the edge of the world.
And then this.
on the wall appears to depict a time of the day perhaps the
candles do too okay yeah the sun is over there so that's
where the sun is i get it i don't do anything here though
right oh gosh don't come to life don't raise don't lift what
are you doing ah no way why were you chilling in here again
I don't understand.
It's kind of a sick beat.
Oh my god.
What did I just press?
Don't press that.
No!
Why are you pressing all the buttons?
You idiot!
Don't press anything.
Elia, please.
You're making me nervous.
Look how many dead...
Oh gosh, I have to walk over this one, though, don't I?
Which has happened?
Okay.
I'm out of here.
Woo!
Oh.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Ew.
Oh, he's...
Oh, when located by creature, a sanity loss occurs causing a
decrease in the levels of the sanity meter and the
characters to pulse green beware sanity loss affects
perception and eventually health um wait so i being located
by creatures oh my god ah i'm just jumping into the thing oh
gosh elphrey thank you that's why your ace detective Minto
because you asked the obvious questions the other cops
didn't know I'm subtly thrown into a thing tutorial jump
scare oh my gosh he doesn't know where I am he doesn't know
where I am oh my god I'm trapped oh uh oh please ouch
performing a finishing move on a creature recover sanity ha
yeah Yeah!
Oh, I had to kill him.
Finish him!
Oh.
Finish him?
Ah!
That was low.
That was a low blow game.
It would have let me finish him.
There was no thing to finish.
There was no like little thing.
Engraved on the floor is striking design.
Featuring a brightly burning sun.
Why?
Oh.
Oh, another bronze necklace.
Hold on, let me turn on my fan.
It's getting hot in there.
Bronze necklace sitting atop an ancient clay urn.
Um, I'll take that.
I'm just gonna take every...
You know what?
This temple has done no service for me.
I'm gonna take everything.
Awesome.
We can see her, like, up close now.
She's so cute.
Look at them cheeks!
Oh yeah!
She is so cute.
The sun is in the middle.
Oh, the design on the wall appears to depict the time of the
day.
Perhaps the candles do too.
Press Y, A, X to light or extinguish the candles.
Okay.
So...
Oh, my bad.
Um...
Oh, okay, so I'm extinguishing this one.
There we go.
Oh.
Do I need to do more?
No?
Nothing else?
Let me in, please.
The door is open slightly, but not enough for Alia to go
over it.
Just use your arms.
It's jammed.
There were two that were jammed, though.
What was the other one?
Oh, gosh.
Hey, Skelly's.
Don't come waking up.
Now ain't the time.
Oh, my God.
I think the thing just popped again.
Oh, gosh.
Um, all right.
Careful.
You know what, Elliot?
Wait.
Which would be...
You know what?
Let's only hit one and not two.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
Nice.
I'm kind of a genius.
Finish him!
Oh gosh, run.
Oh shoot!
Finish him!
Oh, shoot!
Oh!
Ah, I got his arm!
Yeah, I got his other arm!
Ya, I got his head!
Oh!
Finish him!
Finish him.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Uh, take his arm out.
Take his other arm out.
Or finish him.
Yeah!
Whoa!
We did it, baby.
Well, this is...
Um, how it's supposed to look.
Hmm.
She's gaming.
I was first intimidated by the by the system but actually
it's not so bad
was there anything else over here I know that this this door
closed or something the door is now closed preventing
Elliot's passage to the other side what did I miss over here
I should have explored before I grab before I stole
I can't see anything.
The triangular design is carved into the floor.
The etched grooves are filled with colored sand.
The symbols appear to be related to each other with having
one precedence over another.
You got all that information from that?
Where am I supposed to go, though?
Eat the sand.
No.
Was there anything in here?
Oh my gosh, I almost stepped on this one.
I didn't step on it, though, right?
No.
Um.
Look at this guy.
He looks like he's just...
He looks like he's...
He's just like...
Is she gonna notice?
Relation of the three gods is akin to rock, paper, scissors.
We did this one.
And we got the other necklace.
hold on oh let me see what this does can't use it there's
also a map oh okay cinema
okay i'm kind of do i use it here
no maybe down here oh gosh i have to go all the way through
here again oh my god why does it pop
shimmy shimmy passed don't press the button don't press the
button
there's a check option oh that's right what was it that's
right a well-crafted bronze necklace resplendent with
glowing gems oh whoa that didn't really tell me anything
though.
Hmm.
Anything in here.
Blue, red, red, red, green.
Da da da.
Let the candles do too.
Oh, mama!
Where did you get a necklace before?
You guys are so smart!
You want this one?
It's prettier!
Thank you.
Okay, I'm ready to fight.
Maybe.
I'm scared.
This guy's scary.
Okay.
It's a sunset.
Engraved on the floor is a striking design featuring the
sun.
Oh, sorry.
Sunrise.
This one is correct.
The save?
Well, okay.
So I had a bit of an issue with my...
I gotta go find a proper...
A proper...
What's the word?
Memory card.
Because I don't have...
one so I can't really save right now so I just said we'll
we'll we'll deal with that later probably why am I coming up
to a boss or something or is that what you're hinting at is
that what you're hinting at I'm coming up to a boss don't
That would scare me.
Oh.
Rogue-like.
I'll just, uh, I'll just fix it later.
Um, again.
I don't...
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, he is gross.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
He hits hard.
Oh, I got his head.
I got his head.
He hits really hard.
Nice.
Got him.
Oh, he grows his head back!
That's fucked up, that's messed up, that's messed up, that's
messed up!
Finish him!
Oh
my god.
Yikes.
Striking design featuring a starry sky filling the heavens.
Yeah, I can heal, that's right.
I think I just sold my soul.
Oh, we gotta extinguish everything.
This one.
And this one.
It's so dark.
Yay!
Good job selling your soul.
Thank you.
I see them.
see the traps on the ground oh my gosh this one is tight
though
what is this is oh a small pedestal covered with decorative
etching stands before the wall the blowgun upon it must have
some special significance for it to be the focal point of
this display.
Spooky stick.
No, what's on this side?
Nothing.
Everybody only cares about the blowhole, I guess.
Should I take the blowhole?
My first M&M postcard arrives in Germany.
Yubi!
Blue enemies die.
They explode.
The more of them together, the more damage the explosion.
Oh!
So the enemies die.
like different different what's the word powers I suppose oh
it said blow gun I kept saying blow hole I'm so sorry it's a
blow gun
no oh my gosh be careful don't die by your own weapon I
should not have taken the blow gun I hear maelings so much
now Oh my god.
What's happening?
Who are you?
Oh shoot.
I think they noticed me.
Oh, I think I need to get out of here.
I think I need to leave.
I think it's time for me to go.
I think it's time to skedaddle.
Uh oh.
Ah!
Oh my god, skedaddle.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
I think it's time for me to leave.
I think it's time for me to...
That was me, right?
Oh, rip the guy.
Oh.
There was a guy.
You're right.
I should go help him, right?
Um.
How do I attack?
Uh.
He's fine, right?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, what's going on?
Oh, I have a certain number.
is hard.
Might be time to leave.
Ah!
I'm chilling.
Yeah, I'm just gonna chill.
Until the other guy leaves.
I don't have a good weapon anymore.
I shouldn't...
I should have never taken this stupid...
Oh my god.
Punch him!
Ah!
Uh-oh.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Run, run, run.
Oh, he did.
He did.
Oh.
I did it.
My sanity.
I think I did it.
Let me actually finish him so that I can get the sanity
back.
Ah!
Okay, we're good.
Everything's fine.
You're making decent progress if you're here by the time I
got home from work?
Oh, really?
I think I'm just a genius.
Wait, description.
I saw it.
There was a details, but it disappeared.
Oh, examine.
This mural depicts a skeletal demon befriending the ancient
Khmer people by the announcing one of their fertility gods.
Yeah, down with babies, up with demons, yeah!
I see it, they say, yeah, we hate babies.
Yeah, celibacy, yeah, demons.
Demons like, yeah, screw those babies.
Yeah.
Yeah, we hate babies!
I love abstinence!
Hmm.
Whatever happened to the guy that...
I'll be honest, I thought the guy was me.
The guy that was crying in that other room?
Did I really get him killed?
Aw, my bad man.
Oh, what's this here?
Is there anything here?
Oh.
what is this there's a hole in the device as though
something can be inserted perhaps a key or a lever of my my
blowgun obviously bad
end result no it's fine probably wait this is a different
room right oh yeah this is a different room How am I
supposed to get around this trap?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't think I'm supposed to.
I'm supposed to heal me.
My health is still, like, at half, but she's acting like a
little baby about it.
Just selling my soul.
Okay, now it's the...
the only, now just the one that I have to walk through.
Oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot, oh shoot.
Where do they come?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Where do they come through?
I can't tell at all.
Okay, I think I'm alright.
Oh my gosh, I was not alright.
Oh my god, I have to walk through these!
This is so messed up.
Okay.
Alrighty.
I have to walk through this one too!
Yeah!
Ah!
Oh,
the girls are fighting.
I think they're dumb.
I'm just not gonna examine that.
Can I let them fight?
They won't notice me, right?
Nice.
Oh, I think he's noticed me.
Oh my god, run, run, run.
Run,
run, run, run.
He changed colors.
Oh, I didn't do that.
Wait, why is he dying?
Oh, did I poison them?
Oh, interesting.
What?
Padui!
interesting okay i was wondering why they were taking damage
sometimes what is going on here oh my bad the mural depicts
one of the ancient meridavities being tortured and killed by
a skeletal demon wait is this pious
is that pious right there was he in the one before
oh and that's the thing that he the oh it's like the thing
that he Well, it kind of looks like it.
Pius my Oshi.
Okay, she keeps looking up, makes me want to... Okay, so we
came from this door, I remember, so we gotta go this way.
It's Pius!
Thank you, thank you!
Mei Ling!
Oh my god.
My screen is like, do you see this?
If you die without saving, you'll need to start the game all
over again.
Mint.
Try to think ahead and consider what might go wrong.
Oh my god, my screen.
Oh!
This is, uh...
Wowie!
This is the room!
Oh my god.
Hello?
He's asleep.
He's snoring.
Don't mind every eyeball being open.
Stop.
Don't go near it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Why is she chilling in here?
I'm so...
So, you are reduced to feeding on flesh and bone, Matron.
Oh!
How the mighty have fallen.
Don't go near it.
For thee.
You had best leave, young fool.
Okay, I will.
I'm out of here.
How do I get out of here?
How do I get out?
Can you help me?
I'm taking...
You are one of the chosen many.
flesh and blood huh it is now your destiny to fight the
eternal darkness oh she's just passing out i give you a gift
and return for an obligation uh-huh the gift is your life
sweet dancer the obligation is this you hold one of
mantarok's hearts oh the essence of a corpse god of great
power from those people you must defend it I didn't ask for
this use it to destroy with little brightness your world has
left it looks gross it looks oh god these are just gonna
hobble off wait
oh excuse me sir where did you go
the metal staff Is help in the arms of the statue So can we
switch weapons is that what's going on or or rather like if
I wanted to keep one.
Oh my god If I wanted to keep one weapon could I or do I
have to switch.
Wow, we can look at him
Metal staff stop you guys are more brain-rotted than me
Ew side is like hot breath.
We gotta add a new emo before we get grossed.
Maybe we do need a disgust emo, do we?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm going, I'm going.
Okay, okay.
I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going.
What's over here?
Oh, I can look at him.
I'm frozen.
I look like they just took a picture of like Bigfoot I like
orange as much as I like this game thanks Rude I hope you
like it too it was one of my favorites to get through
through all the endings yeah I am curious about that um not
quite sure how I want to approach that yet a statue of a
human female bears witness to the monstrosity that fills the
room stone of its body is covered with the effluvial grime
that Manta rock has secreted over the years.
Oh.
I know there's probably going to be someone that's like,
this should have been me.
Oh, yeah, I want your nasty stone or nasty whatever all over
me.
This should have been me.
What's over here?
Okay.
Same thing?
Oh, yeah.
Give me your effluvial grime!
We should bring that kind of language back.
I don't even know what effluvial means.
But I just know some sicko out there is just like, Shut up
in me!
Shut up in me!
Saku-dal!
Effluvial grime, baby!
The door of formidable size seals the vault.
A stylized design resembling the creature that dwells within
the room.
What do you mean the creature that dwells within the room?
It's carved into the stone.
What do you mean by that?
Like, oh, this room?
Can I use the staff?
No?
What do I do here now?
Means this guy.
Okay.
Wasn't sure if it meant...
Oh, that just looks like the sun up there.
Okay.
Am I going back?
Time to leave with my staff.
Does the staff...
Oh, shoot!
No, no, no!
Wait, I...
Oh, I can't equip it.
It's not a weapon.
Basically means stinky.
Oh!
I flew veal.
This had no booby traps.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Just running.
Just getting out of here.
Bye.
What's with the music?
Are there guys in here?
At least I know.
They're gonna step on something.
They're gonna really mess something up for me.
Uh...
I can't tell.
Oh boy, the Dutch angle.
Wait!
Oh, dang it.
I thought I could walk through it.
Ow!
Oh my god.
Oh shoot, they noticed me.
Oh!
Do you think they're getting attacked?
Or do you think...
I think they're getting sliced and diced by this thing.
Oh god, they're starting- Oh my god.
What's going on?
What's happening?
I think I hear them still walking around.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh.
Everything is happening!
I think I just have to go through it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
My feet.
My everything.
Okay, I guess the guys died.
Which is great for us.
I think.
Well, it would be great.
This looks like you could go around it, doesn't it?
Doesn't this look like you could avoid it somehow?
It does.
Who's talking?
Hello?
Me?
I'm just, I'm looking pretty.
I don't care about you guys.
Okay, I'm just gonna run for it then.
I'm scared, though.
Accidentally.
Okay.
Setting off a trap is what I was gonna say!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
Did I get hurt?
Where am I supposed to go?
Am I just backtracking all the way?
There's no way.
I have to backtrack so far.
I'm just running through things, though.
Oh, my sanity!
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, oh my god, no.
Oh my sanity is so low, that's why.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Step over the pressure plates.
Yeah, you know, that would be great.
Oh shoot, oh shoot.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we have to kill to regain sanity, you're right.
Oh my gosh.
If I could find a guy to kill.
What's going on?
What am I looking at?
Hello?
Oh, this is my... my sword.
What's going on?
This is where the guy was.
Maybe he was part of my low sanity.
She looked right at... she's looking at me.
It's kind of freaky.
I wish I could get my sword.
Oh, I can pick it up.
Can I fix it somewhere?
Shut up.
It is completely useless.
You could have fixed it if you saved the guy.
No way!
Aw man.
Okay, alright.
If anybody wants to backseat him where I need to go.
That'd be great.
I think we're gonna have to go kill some guys in here.
Oh shoot, run, run, run.
Just poison him.
Poison each guy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Poison him.
Oh, he's down.
He's down.
Finish him.
Get him.
Hey, hey, I was trying to do a move here, okay?
God.
No!
You're ruining my shell!
You're ruining my...
winning it for me!
Oh my god.
Please leave.
Please.
Oh, please.
Oh, stop hugging me.
Please stop hugging me.
It's icky and gross.
Finish him!
There we go.
There's one.
There's two.
And let's get this guy.
Oh my god!
We're gonna have to heal, though.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should heal again, just in case.
It doesn't give you so much health.
That's okay.
Sanity up.
Oh, here we go.
That's right.
I forgot about this.
What the...
Okay, perfect.
The metal staff.
We did it.
I forgot about here.
He probably wasn't real anyway.
Oh, I have to go all the way back.
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
It was this way, right?
Girl has...
Girl does not care.
Girl has zero cares ever.
I love...
chanting.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, shoot.
My toes.
I can't see.
Ouch!
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Screw.
Get it.
This is so bad.
Alright.
Here we go.
Run!
Just run!
Ouchie ouch!
Oh shoot.
I forgot about these guys over here.
Bye!
What?
What are you saying?
I didn't...
I...
Sorry.
What?
What are you saying?
Was that me?
Who did that?
Just go.
Just get out of here.
shaking
oh okay that's okay catch your breath in here i think it's
safe it's probably safe it's it's it's fine she's going to
lulu me too oh oh you should have run yeah i agree where is
the essence of
Uh-oh.
They're coming at me slowly.
Oh.
They're being really gentle with me, actually.
Where is it?
I will not ask again, child.
It's in my tummy.
Very well, then.
You will succumb to the horrors of oblivion.
No!
Chapter Cup.
Whoa,
freaky!
Oh, how did they...
A small shrine of candles, their placement appears to be
very deliberate corresponding to etchings on the table.
And an illustration upon the wall.
Some of the candles have been lit!
Oh, now which ones do I extinguish?
Um...
That was the end of her chapter, alright?
What the hell is going on in this game?
What is going on in this game?
I still have the broken key.
What if Alex's grandpa just did that and he died of natural
causes?
Yeah, the beheading totally naturally.
is there hold on oh i see it i see the sun up top so maybe
just uh those oh i see i see okay i see it i was like
looking for it okay so this one and this one
oh there we go with the correct sequence of candles being
lit a hidden panel opens there is a message tube inside his
head just did that We got the message tube!
Okay, interesting.
This game is originally for the N64.
The game was so unplayable that Nintendo needs to save it.
There used to be a knight and military soldier section that
got cut.
There's footage of...
Oh my god, seriously?
An antique leather-bound message tube.
The kind used to transport sealed message scrolls.
It appears to be unopened.
There might be something inside.
Yes, open it.
Suspicions of conspiracy!
Let's go!
Oh.
What?
Your presence is welcomed, Majesty.
Pius Augustus.
As always, I am honored.
Our dealings are a pleasure towards both of them.
lies as do yours what is this you wish to discuss with us my
concern is with the other ancients yeah Ulioth Chaturka
should they unite with Mantarok they would doubtlessly
possess enough power to vanquish even these as darkness
appores light and light appores dark the others will not
cannot join forces
sink into insanity when i return as has been foretold i was
unaware there is much you do not know and much you never
will be certain to retrieve mandrake's essence it is
necessary to cement our place in your world then what of
charlemagne the frank oh charlemagne the frank the frank is
an instrument of light he seeks to unite under his banner
with this in place my guardians will be hard-pressed to
perform the functions you require for your own schemes I
like how like she just keeps breaking apart then Charlemagne
will be removed from the picture make sure he is dead or
insane or perhaps one and the other just make sure he is
removed from power of course he is as good as dead okay why
why why it's going on why is going on after the chapter page
is removed the message tube is no longer needed alex
discards it so oh here's our chapter page suspicions of
conspiracy but before we do that i've noticed Also, our
sanity meter is going down, it seems a little bit.
We still have some stuff in here.
I guess we still can't do it, though.
Like the...
Where's the meter?
Is that not it right there?
The little bubbly?
The bubbly?
It was here, right?
Okay.
Equip the Gladius.
Can I?
Oh, I can!
Let's go.
Wait, why'd you tell me to do that?
There's not gonna be dead guys in here, are there?
I sure hope not.
What's this thing?
Hmm.
This looks like a suspiciously interesting area.
That door sound.
Sounds so old.
Yeah, we have to fix the key.
And we need to use the dresser key.
Hey, why is the book blinking at us over there?
Why is there an eyeball?
I just noticed it.
Um, hello?
Excuse me?
Why are we opening our eyes?
Why is everybody asleep and you are...
You're wired?
You're like...
Blink back at it.
Oh, goodness, I'm sleepy.
Oh, let's do the suspicions of conspiracy, I suppose.
From my research, it is apparent that the endeavors of
mankind are mere puppetry at the hands of the ancients.
Whenever a king vows reform, the ancients move quickly to
stifle it.
of Emperor Charlemagne the Frank the new Holy Roman Empire
was at the height of its power
France of Saxon's Creed
So what is this at dominum at Imperatorum nostrum Karolum
magnum Frankum deliver this to our Lord and Oh, we're
smarter no one but him must see it there are words for his
eyes only okay What is this lighting?
Why does that background look like a...
Like a Looney Tunes painted background?
This guy's just... This guy's looking real smart.
Oh!
You're reading it!
What sorcery is this?
Uh-oh.
Spell?
I am bewitched!
This was meant for Charlemagne, then...
What will become of him?
Uh-oh.
this treachery uh-oh into the looney tunes
a little hunchback of notre dame hours here they have come
from looney tune land i must speak after anthony briefly
describes his mission the monk informs him that charlemagne
was last seen in audience with the bishop in the visiting
chamber what about you anthony His presence is questioned by
the monks, feeling that he has trespassed upon sacred
ground.
The monk seems rather subdued, perhaps out of respect or
perhaps out of fear.
Um, is this not a church?
Can't everybody come here?
I'm here to pray.
I am a holy man.
Visibly disturbed with grief and despair, the monk sobbed.
Oh, it's a funeral.
You're just a god.
he recounts that this is oh my goodness sorry I keep yawning
he recounts that this is not the only death to have occurred
recently and wonders if perhaps the order is being punished
for a wavering in faith
the monk cordially greets Anthony however he brings grave
news of the loss of one of his order who fell from the tower
sorry sorry He just fell?
Oh, man.
Sorry.
Sorry, Mr. I thought I don't know.
I just expected something else.
Not like...
Oh, he tripped and he fell.
His tone is guarded, leaving Anthony wondering if indeed
this is the truth.
Oh.
I can't open the camera.
A funeral casket made from unfinished wood.
It is not properly sealed and could probably be open.
Should Anthony open the casket?
No, but yes.
Oh, my God.
What is the object?
This is devil's work.
We should get out of here.
Why is everybody saying that?
I have proven what we have feared the most.
This poor man has been the victim of great evil.
Uh-oh.
Look, how his body has been defiled.
as if something has burst out from inside him here take this
for your protection did they not even look at him find the
bishop he must be informed of this horrible discovery did
they not even I got this scrum sacks scrum sacks it has like
a xenomorph
What do you expect me to do?
I'm just a guy.
Oh, no, I didn't get to finish talking to them.
Oh, buddy.
Had a rough.
Peering inside the casket, Anthony sees the body of a monk.
His ray mint.
Ray mint is that of his order.
Stained with blood that has seeped from many grievous
wounds.
It is a truly disturbing sight.
Anthony is voiced by Liquid Sna- Cam Clark!
And you're in a monastery surrounded by monks.
Which means you have an excuse to call them all brother!
Not a great track record for these playable characters so
far.
Do your best, Tony.
Rhymeant?
Rhymeant.
Riden?
Uh, I should have quit my...
My...
Scra...
what is this message oh message goals like this were often
used to transfer messages securely this one has a strange
diagram on it consisting of a pentagonal shape with strange
letters at each corner oh when Anthony had opened the scroll
something strange happened something had been intended for
the Emperor Charlemagne suspecting a plot against the
Emperor Anthony pledged that he would warn Charlemagne at
all costs.
Also natural causes.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, oh, this is all connected.
I thought I was going down a hallway.
He's not going to get out of that thing, right?
Oh, what's over here?
Muffled voices emanate from inside the bishop's visiting
chamber.
However, the door is locked and Anthony will need the
bishop's key to enter and gain an audience with...
Like, you could...
The monks could not give this to me?
They knew that they were like, oh yeah, yeah, you really
need to talk to that guy.
Good luck.
By the way, good luck.
Yeah, just knock.
Come on, Anthony, use your hands.
Three minty months, thank you!
Charlemagne, do you like my sunglasses?
Anthony cannot leave yet.
Charlemagne must be warned of the conspiracy against him.
And also, like, everything that's going on is kind of crazy.
What are you looking at, Anthony?
He's just really powering through these stairs.
Oh!
Anthony, how did you get here?
Anthony!
What did you do?
Where are we?
Anthony!
Oh my god, they're screaming on the ground!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, that's so cool!
Step, step, step, step, step.
Step, step, step, step, step, step.
It's the tomb.
Cradled in what appears to be a leathery hand lies a
mysterious book.
It is bound in human skin and intricately decorated with
shrunken bones.
It beckons... Shut up!
Shut up!
It beckons and yearns to be possessed.
Should Anthony claim the Tome of Eternal Darkness?
Uh, sure.
Anthony has acquired the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Anthony is not the same as before.
Can Anthony keep going up here?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Oof!
Ouch!
What?
I'm not Anthony anymore.
anymore.
Liquid Anthony.
The sound of chat would have meant it's too late to stream.
Stop!
What's this?
A blue urn.
I'll take that.
I'm taking everything.
Honestly.
Anthony, you don't look so good.
I'm gonna be honest, buddy.
Oh, a mysterious gold medallion rests upon the desk.
I'm gonna take that too.
Oh, maybe not.
Oh, acquired a circle of power.
Anthony, are you okay?
Oh, no way.
Describe the amount of power that a spell will have.
The more points within that circle, the stronger the spell
will be.
We have spells now?
Spells are magical?
Why is it spelled with a K?
Magical incantations that enhance a character's natural
abilities.
The spell list is an inventory of all the spell information
that have been acquired.
It will allow the player to select which spells to cast,
examine, or assign to convenient quick spell buttons.
New spell... Oh my gosh.
Selecting this will allow the player to experiment with rune
combinations and discover new spells.
Paragon.
Is that a spell you learn?
It's not real magic.
It's magical.
This section is an inventory of all the components of Magic
Cow's spells you have acquired.
With this function, the player can review their current
assignment of spells to the quick spell buttons.
Okay, I can... I'm a wizard.
Anthony, you're a wizard!
You're a wizard, Anthony.
What's in here?
Oh my god, Anthony, you are a real jump scare.
Amongst the tomes and manuscripts, a book brings attention
to itself.
Oddly pristine on the dusty shelf, it doesn't quite belong.
Yeah, take the book, Anthony.
Oh!
Amongst us.
A bewildering array of books and tomes sorted neatly on a
set of shelves.
Mostly books of a religious nature.
They sit beneath a skiing.
A skiing of dust.
as if no one has touched them.
Oh, sorry.
There we go.
Charlemagne, I can do...
I can cast spells now.
Somehow.
I'm actually not quite sure how.
Excuse me.
Is this that...
Is this that moi moi magic to make eternal screams taste
better?
Yes.
Wait, where'd my spell go?
New spell.
Anthony does not have enough components to attempt to read
their spells.
You can't even attempt to read.
Anthony is not smart.
Anthony can't even attempt to do anything.
Anthony, you need to take a...
Anthony, you need to know your place, Anthony.
My god.
I only have circle runes.
I know nothing.
Level zero, mage.
Alrighty.
Climb down.
You guys, I'm going to be honest.
I'm kind of nervous about continuing on without saving.
So I might actually cut today a little short.
Because if something happens and I have to play all the way
back to this part before stream, I don't want to have to go
through so much.
You know what I mean?
Honest, please be honest.
So I might actually cut today kind of short.
And then next time, go pretty long.
This game is so wacky, but I'm having so much fun with it
already.
I know, it's such a short stream today.
But I'm going to find out what I can do.
with i think i have a memory card somewhere i just have to
get it i just have to find it wherever wherever but um yeah
so next week we will um continue it and um yeah but it was
good to kind of i don't even know if i can say get a feel of
this game because i don't even know what the hell is
I don't even know what is happening, but it's fascinating.
I will, I will, it's still, you're still pretty early on.
Oh yeah, we're barely, we're barely in.
So, um, just a taste.
You've just entered the game proper, I am all.
It is definitely interesting.
Thanks for the stream, I can't wait.
Yes, I'm really sorry.
I will, um, I will do this.
I will like that too a little bit.
I know, it's so short.
because I don't want to just end the stream.
Give me a second to...
Changeover.
There
we go.
Okay.
I think that'll stop the...
Oh, no, I can still hear it.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, yeah, wait.
You guys can still even see it.
That's crazy.
I'm not going to have it run for too long.
We'll chat to for a bit, though.
Um...
For a Minto.
Give me one second.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la.
I feel bad.
I feel bad that I'm like playing the game for such a short
amount of time.
But again, I'm just really nervous.
If something happens.
And then I have to play back up to this point.
And then I'd be like I have to take all this time.
To play up to this point.
Let's see, let's put on some music.
Let's put on...
I hope you guys are liking it, too.
Even though it's like, what the hell is going on?
I've seen Let's Players lose hours of progress.
I know!
And I'm just nervous about it.
So, it is an older game, too.
So, it's whack in a good way.
Yeah, I was really exhausted from work this week, but this
stream really helped me down wide.
Oh, Herma Kitty, thank you!
you had a such a bad week.
So, uh, blooms?
No, no, no.
We can do shorter days someday, sometimes.
But not maybe the best day to choose a shorter day.
I just didn't realize the...
I'm so sorry, I didn't realize the...
The memory card.
Can't believe we just got a demo of Mint's gameplay of
Eternal Darkness.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me of like when I would play.
Oh my gosh, what was that game?
There was one demo of a game I would play all the time
because I didn't own the actual thing.
It was a guy, it was a guy that was a Skullman.
It was from the PlayStation wide.
I can't have anything in Eternal Darkness world.
What are you talking about, Anthony?
Spank, thanks for the 20 gift.
Yes, Med Evil!
Oh my gosh, I played the demo of Med Evil Never played the
actual game.
Medieval.
Wait, did I spell it wrong?
Evil.
There it is.
Oh, Medi-Medieval.
Why is it spelled like that?
Have you ever thought about streaming TTRPGs?
I don't know.
I've never been like a TTRPG kind of ghost.
So...
Um...
I can't really say.
I've never played them so much before.
Did I miss the gameplay?
Yes, I'm sorry.
Take care, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, we're just hanging out for a little bit before I head
out.
Because I don't want to also keep my GameCube running if I
can help.
For as long as I can help it, you know.
Hmm.
It is the gameplay.
Yeah, a bit of a shorter stream today.
But yeah, I played Medieval a ton.
I think, I feel like if I name the, I only ever had one
PlayStation demo disc.
I feel like if I name it, people will be able to find it so
easily.
Because it was Medieval.
I don't remember if it was one or two.
It might have been two.
But it was Medieval and Emperor's New Groove.
I played that one all the time too.
Which it had like three levels.
It had...
What did it have?
It had like the village level and then it had the spider
level and then it had this roller coaster level.
That's how often I played it.
That's how much I played it because I can still remember
everything.
My favorite demo discos, the one with Spyro the dragon on
it.
See, I never had Spyro 1 but I played Spyro 2.
My first experience with MGS1 was a PS1 demo disc.
I remember it had JP voices.
No way!
I never...
I know, despite having a PlayStation 1, I never had played
Metal Gear.
Thanks for this treatment!
Yippie, three months!
Yippie!
I had one with Tony Hawk.
I think mine also had...
Tony Hawk.
I had some sort of skateboarding game, I think.
Hmm.
do you have fortnight ridden skin no i have snake skin i
never got ridden skin i actually couldn't figure out how to
get ridden skin on fortnite i have snake and i tried to get
old snake but it was too difficult i wasn't i wasn't gamer
enough yeah ridden was just one you buy but it wasn't
showing up in my store Yeah, yeah.
True.
I used to swap in and out of demo discs in my PS1 while the
motor was still spinning in order to import games.
What?
When they had shattered in my hand and forced me to find a
better way.
Was your hand okay?
Was your PlayStation okay?
What shattered?
What are you talking about?
I don't even know you could do that.
Wait, we're back in the day were games region locked?
Like that?
Because they were?
No way!
PS1 and PS2 were region locked.
Seriously?
What?
Let's see.
Nowadays, it's like getting... I think the last thing that I
can think of that was region locked was like the 3DS.
I can't think of Unless I'm just dumb Could be PlayStation
Magazine Demo Disc 44 Which also had MGS1 No way, don't tell
me that Hold on, I'm gonna go look it up PS Magazine Demo
Disc 44
Wait But the magazine looks familiar Wait, hold on Don't
tell me that I had Metal Gear this whole time.
No.
Hold on.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
This isn't... No, no, no.
This isn't the... No, because this doesn't even have
medieval.
Watch the Let's Play of Eternal Darkness over 11 years ago,
according to YouTube, and forgot about it ever since.
all coming back to me.
It's definitely weird.
When I was like 10, my brother had my mom drive us an hour
to buy Eternal Darkness from a game stop that had it.
It's really amazing to see you play.
I've always wanted to see more of the game when I was a kid.
Oh, awesome!
Glad that we can be fulfilling these childhood these
childhood dreams, right?
It has medieval.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, the magazine is show...
Oh wait.
Wait, no, but it's showing me on the magazine.
It's showing like Baldur's Gate and Ace Combat 4.
I can't see what's on the disc.
I can't tell.
The disc is too small.
The pictures are too small.
Wait a second, hold on.
Oh wait, Disney's Emperor New Groove.
Ape Escape!
Medieval 2.
Metal Gear Solid!
No, no, no.
Did I play PlayStation?
PlayStation Demo Disc Emperor's New Gruel.
No, I found it.
I found the one that I had.
Wait, hold on.
It has...
It wasn't...
Okay, I found it.
I found it Because I remember It was Oh that I'll save the
image I found it It doesn't have metal gear I was like this
The What's it called The thing itself Like the disc itself
Looked familiar But I think Because this was the disc And it
had Oh my gosh It's so hard to read Yeah Had medieval 2 also
on it And the emperor's new groove Oh I was pro BMX That I
was thinking of It was pro BMX.
I knew I was like some sort of sports get, not sports, but
you know, like I was like, it's either it's either
skateboard.
Oh, I did have skateboarding.
Grind session!
Yeah, this is the this is the exact one I had because I
recognized the the the sleeve.
Oh my gosh, though.
Can you imagine?
I was one step away from glory.
I was...
If I had just got the magazine one, I don't even know how I
got this one.
What if I had just gotten the magazine one?
I would have...
I would have had Metal Gear!
An ape escape!
You ever check the snake Sam Fisher death battle?
What?
Dad Mint got it?
Maybe.
Maybe, yeah.
Did you get it from Pizza Hut?
Oh, maybe.
I don't know I have no idea It's just in my memory I do not
have a way of How I acquired it I used to even play MLB
I just realized that the That the dates of the games Really
kind of exposed me Oh
and what's it at a beam?
Frigate spaghetti Everybody It's a good It's fine I'm a
ghost I've been around for a while It's fine I'm a ghost
here in similar company yippee till we all have our bad ps1
era sports sports games I would play yeah I would play the
MLB one I played grind session I played medieval a lot I
loved medieval And I love the Emperor's New Groove game.
I played that one a lot too.
But, um, oh my gosh, even on the back of the box, it shows
the spider level that I talked about.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, I can't believe that I almost had Metal Gear.
But I don't remember ever buying, like, the...
Um...
The magazines.
Not even my dad got them, so...
Not even my dad got them.
But now I want to find it.
PlayStation Magazine Demo Disc 44.
4-4!
It's even lucky for me!
4 is such a spooky number!
I think there are PS1 demo discs floating around with the
Titan AE game demo.
It's the only way to play that game since the full game was
canceled.
Really?
Did you try games by renting them at Blockbuster?
Sometimes.
i'm trying to think of what games i you know i'll be honest
like completely um i think because i didn't play so many
games when i was a kid is because i was obsessed with
pokemon and that was all i wanted to play all i wanted to
play was pokemon and so i really didn't branch out so much
more i had other games but i just always just i would i
would go to the bathroom with my game boy and pretend that
like i was pooping for hours my mom would be like are you
okay in there mint i'd be like yeah my tummy hurts i'm just
i'm like on sabrina
oh death battle is a youtube channel they animate fights
between characters oh check it out
And then, you know, I would watch my dad play games.
He'd like to play a lot of stuff.
And, uh...
I had an N64.
I only saw demo discs through friends.
I didn't have...
I only had the PlayStation.
Well, I had PlayStation and Game Boy.
That was what...
I...
That might...
I actually...
Well, all my stuff was like hand-me-downs from my sisters.
And so, my sister, she had a...
Sega Nomad.
so I got to play games from that because of her so um but
that's you had a Sega Nomad I know right I almost caught I
almost said the Sega Genesis but I was like no no what was
it called the Nomad the Nomad was the portable one I think I
might still have it somewhere and I have I basically, I only
had the Sonic games, the Lion King game.
I thought about playing that recently.
I was like, I should...
Oh, I had Echo the Dolphin.
That is my trauma.
It's my actual trauma.
It is a Genesis, but portable.
Right, right, right.
It's like huge.
I had even a battery pack for the back.
And, um...
It, like, it...
It took, like, seven batteries or something.
It was crazy.
Return to the ocean.
Minto, would you consider playing other PS1 Aerotactical
espionage action games like Siphon Filter or Splinter Cell?
Well, I just...
I don't like...
I don't like stealth.
I don't like stealth games!
Metal Gear is my...
is my exception.
Baby Koi, thanks for that gift!
I really...
don't like stealth though.
I really kind of took a gamble.
Like, truly, I don't know why I played Metal Gear.
Like, rather...
When I started with Revengeance, I was like, this seems like
a silly game.
And it was before, like, the big hype and everything
happened.
and even then I was so like you know that was fun I don't
actually know why I started Metal Gear
and have you considered playing Devil May Cry games yes it's
on my list for sure playing MGS1 demo in the 90s was all
mind blowing I truly don't know why because I like I said I
hate stealth i think i just kind of was like at the time
thinking this is a game series that is so influential and
you know everybody knows about snake and his clapping
clapping cheeks and i was like i kind of want to know more
about that and then it all snowballed and went downhill
My brain, my brain chemistry has been forever altered.
Moira, welcome to membership!
The memes got her.
I don't even think it was me being like, oh, I want to know
more about what they were talking about in Revengeance.
Because I'll be honest, I mean, I was so confused.
But even thinking about it now, I don't think that's so much
connected.
They talk about the Patriots.
The Patriots a little bit, but...
What about some PS1 action games?
Chase the Express.
It's like a Tom Cruise film as a game.
Parasite Eve!
Oh my gosh, I always wanted to play Parasite Eve.
Forever goal.
So glad you're here.
Kazami, thank you!
Mint pie, thank you!
MG fanstom.
True.
words ever spoken.
Kind of want to know about them cheeks.
Mint tomato.
Yeah, I was like, I want to know about those cheeks.
Hmm.
Oh yeah, it's so weird.
Like when I think about how me going into Metal Gear was all
just chance.
It was all just, maybe you would say it was fate.
Hmm.
And so, that's kind of why I've also been like trying to
play some other games that you don't see so many people
streaming very often because at the time, nobody was
streaming Metal Gear.
You had Pecora who streamed it before and I didn't even get
to watch her VODs because they all got removed but now she's
replayed them but I'm just kind of like it's kind of just
like
I think my chat's delayed Wait, I think my everything is
delayed Uh-oh, hold on, one second I'm refreshing
There we go But yeah, so I've been just been trying to You
know, like with this game as well Just trying to get through
some things that Maybe people don't touch as much In terms
of VTuber playthroughs
Perhaps I even actually based on a JP novel oh is it really
oh my gosh my chat is all messed up everything's all messed
up after the release of ace combo 7 for the switch band I
already announced merch for the games I'm so excited they
got a JPEG dog sticker no way MG has mint those great
streams oh my gosh that reminds me I was on ami ami last
night and guys hold on I have I have to, I have to, I
already have it up.
I already have it pulled up.
Look, look at this.
I saw this last night and I nearly screamed.
Outer Wilds, archaeologist edition.
Oh my gosh, look, oh my god.
And then also the Ami Ami Gente item, if you pre-order from
Ami Ami, you can also get an acrylic key holder.
But also the ones that are...
Look how cute!
And the middle thing is like a...
It says it's a fabric poster.
Rather than like a wall scroll.
But it's probably, you know, you can make it into a wall
scroll.
So...
Hmm.
Okay, and Trace is really interesting.
I'm finally looking forward to them.
Thank you!
YouTube Y.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
It's all like kind of...
Chat is all kind of delayed and stuff.
I thought it was just me.
My stream is all messed up, like it's all delayed.
But yeah, isn't it so cute?
It comes with the little key chains.
And it also comes with the DLC.
I love Outer Wilds.
I was like, oh no, I guess I'll have to buy it.
I ordered the limited edition from IM8bit.
Of Outer Wilds?
How's the fabric bag?
Wait.
I am able.
I'm going.
I'm viewing.
What?
The bag is so cool.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Hold on.
I'll show you guys a picture.
Property of Outer Wild Adventures.
No way.
This is the one you were talking about.
I don't understand the scart, like the, the ascot though.
Art, not vital.
I don't really understand that.
But the book looks really cool.
All the little badges and stuff of the different planets are
really cute.
So this is the archaeologist edition, but in, in Western, I
suppose.
Try Ninja Turtles games.
Bet nobody does that.
Oh yeah, there's a kazoo down there too.
It's so cute.
Wow.
Oh wait, it says Canvas Traveler's Adventure Bag Explorers
Journal plus Game Sleeve.
Oh, so it's not like an art book.
It's a journal.
Oh, it's Church Bandana.
Set of seven planetary patches.
Bonus item from a doomed timeline.
Okay.
Eye of the Universe Clasp.
Base game plus Echoes of the Eye expansion.
Region free.
Worldwide capability.
So the Kazoo is the bonus eye.
It's not even like...
It's like all blacked out.
Ace Combat 7-Sikers is going to be on Rakuten JP website.
And then there's F16 Model Kit.
Ooh!
Wait, I wonder if Amiami will have a special pre-order item
to not the doom kazoo can't wait for you to play Xenoblade
eventually eventually it is on the list it is on the list of
stuff we'll get there we'll get there eventually gotta get
through we gotta get through Metal Gear first again oh my
gosh shut up they have Oh no!
There, no!
This 8-I am 8-bit place had vinyl soundtracks!
Oh my gosh, I collected, I bought like one Metal Gear vinyl
and now I got the Steinsgate vinyl and, oh, but they're sold
out!
Oh my gosh, I would cry though, I would put it on and I
would cry.
Oh!
I think Outer Wilds is like to me even more so a super
special series because Um, it was one of the last things I
played back in heaven and so You know and the ending is just
so like And so to me it just means this like has like such a
special meaning That I
Like what was the word I Um Have good memories with it, you
know, should you buy a turntable yet?
No, not yet Honestly, I wasn't going to get one until the
Metal Gear ones shipped, but they sold the Steinsgate ones
at the Jast booth at AX.
And so I got that.
So now I actually have something that's worth...
That will need a turntable.
It's an ending and a new beginning.
Outer Wilds music still makes me tear.
up and it's been years.
It's so...
It's so weird.
Acceptance of an end that brings a new beginning.
Fitting, huh?
Yeah, somehow.
Somehow it ended up that way.
Oh, and they also had a vinyl soundtrack that was a
pre-order of Echoes of the Eye music.
But isn't that, like, kind of creepy?
It says, Secrets from the Outer Wild.
Read at your own risk.
It's so cool.
Wow, the art is, the art goes hard.
Look at this.
Actually, this is like so genius.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, I have to save it like this.
Oh, hold on.
Actually, let me do this.
Um, whoop.
Uh.
One second.
I'm getting new pictures.
Okay, so this is the...
This one's so sweet.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting new pictures.
picture so you could see oh sorry they're different sizes
save okay there we go um
i'm so sad that they're sold out though but the one on the
right is from like you know obviously it's it's the outer
wilds proper and then the one on the left is from the is
from the um dlc but it's so cool because like they have like
the part that like it looks like the vinyl is ripped and
then it shows the secret planet it looks so cool oh the
covers are so nice the left one looks so cool i know such a
cool sleeve so glad and understandable that outer wilds
means that much to you as well it's been one of my favorite
series to watch you play thank you nexi ghostbusters the
video game 2009 busted busted i oh my gosh every time i'm on
the plane i always see ghostbusters and i'm like i should
watch it it's been like i think i've only watched it ever
once and it was you know probably when i was a kid but i
don't think i can watch it without like without busting i
like this the song is just ruined for me i can't do the
original anymore the original song
watch along october watch along
Maybe.
It got the Ghostbusters brain rot.
I don't think it goes that hard.
Neil C.
Sierga remixes a straight-up improvement.
It's just so funny.
Such a good...
Such a good.
Speaking of...
Thank you guys for...
Hanging out with me today.
As always.
for, um, again, I'm, I know I keep apologizing, but I feel
so bad.
I wanted to keep playing for real, but I was just nervous
that if I have to start over, I don't want to start over.
I don't want to, I don't want to go through the two hours
again.
Even though I know what to do now, I could have, but if I,
if I have to, I can.
And then I could just, I'm going to try and figure it out um
and again if i have to if i can't figure out a way to save
it i will i will make the next stream an endurance stream so
i can at least beat it and then maybe we'll do like uh you
could find new things oh my gosh we could save that guy came
in kind of late i don't know what's going on
You cut it close at the temple, so it was a good decision.
I know.
It's just going to get harder, too, right?
But I gamed a little bit.
I gamed a little bit.
Endurance.
I don't think I'll do all three endings.
Maybe I'll do one of them, and then we watch the other two.
Or...
Or not...
It's not three endings.
I play it three times, and then I...
Uh...
Watch, I don't know.
I'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out as we do.
Anyway, better safe than sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, next stream, next couple of days, I'll get it.
Well, hopefully next couple of days.
I'll get it figured out, I promise.
I promise!
Oh, it's my brain.
I don't even think about it.
sorry okay everybody ozumito it is time to do our goodbye
ritual in that we will be busting together um uh busting
oh my god it's loud
What's your bussing?
What's your minnow?
Did it!
If there's something strange, sleeping in your bed.
Da, da, da, da, da.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird, sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you some!
Oh!
I'm obsessed with the...
B-B-B-Bust.
B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-L-B-B-B-B-D-L-D-D-D-D-D-L-D, you're seeing
things.
Sleeping in your bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Invisible man.
Sleaping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you some.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Busting, busting, busting.
Makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good, feel good.
Freaky ghost maid!
Freaky ghost man!
Freaky man, baby!
Oh, I love you all alone!
Let me sleep in your bed!
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
I like the freaking music here.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tomorrow will be a membership stream.
I think I do karaoke.
Um, so, yeah.
Uh, if you are a member, you will get a membership karaoke
stream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll make the waiting room right after this.
A kiss!
Thanks for the five gifts!
Ring a hat, thanks for the five, Gipton, Murphy, thanks for
the 10, Gipton, viral bug, thanks for the 10, Gipton.
Thank you, guys, oh my god, thank you so much, thank you,
thank you, thank you, feel good, feel good, thank you, no,
thanks for the Gipton.
Feel good, feel, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Xenopal, thanks for the 10, Gipton, thank you guys for the
stream.
Again, I'm so sorry that it was so short.
Halo, thanks for the Gipton.
Oh my goodness, oh, I'm too big.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, wait, I'm trying to scroll up.
Oh, my god.
Oh, Krobert, thanks for the Gipton.
five gifted, Seagulls, thanks for the five gifted, S17B32,
thank you for the five gifted, Zao, thanks for the 10
gifted, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh,
there's too many, and thanks for the five gifted, world is
such, thanks for the five gifted, mistress, thanks for the
one, 10, see, see, see two, see, see, see two, so, so,
thanks for the five gifted, star creator, thanks for the 10
gifted, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, there's
so many, I have to play it again.
Okay, so here, Andrew, thanks for the 5-gifted.
Mr. Albee, thanks for the 10-gifted.
Andrew, thanks for the 10-gifted.
Saddamo's, thanks for the 10-gifted.
Hi!
Must embark, thank you for the 10-gifted.
Wow!
The rice knot, right?
Thanks for the 5-gifted.
Maxi, thanks for the 10.
I'd rather not thanks for the 10!
Oh, oh, oh, they catch up.
Yuki!
Thanks for the 10!
West-San by, stand by, stand.
And Drinker's thanks for the 10!
Lino, Chad, thanks for the 10.
Superliminal, thanks for the 10!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Rock, Rack for Rabbit, thanks for the 10.
Folder Ranger, thanks for the 10.
Sleaping in your bed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Silver and nuclear.
Makes for the 10.
You guys, please.
Gumbull, thanks for the 10.
Notorious Bruce G!
Thanks for the gift card.
Clockwork, thanks for the 10.
Chat, is this real?
I don't know.
Fight stars, thanks for the three of us.
Okay.
Try Princess, thanks for the five, gifted.
Thank you.
Do,
do, do, do, freaky ghost man!
Pirate book, thanks for the 10!
Larry, thanks for the 5!
Freaky man, baby.
Clockwalk, thanks for the 10!
Good night, man.
Good night, 9.
Phew!
Vice eyes, thanks for the 10!
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
MK, thanks for the 10!
Rest in glitch phase, thanks for the 5!
I don't feel like I can end this.
because I don't want to cut off the song.
Ronaldo, thanks for that, bye!
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost memberships!
I mean, gifted memberships.
Biz, thank you for the 10.
We're just, we're, we're freaky, freaky ghost.
Oh, oh.
Wrong thing.
I see, thanks for the 10 gifting.
You guys don't have to give gifting.
It's okay.
You guys don't have to give Gifton You guys don't, it's okay
David, thanks for the five It's okay, we can just vibe to
the music It's alright It is a ghost membership
Gifton makes us feel good No, it's our creator Thank you for
that, Tawari You already did so ready though
Okay, no gifted Okay, no gifted Moitak, welcome.
Tonwin, thank you for the five.
JPNG, thanks for the five.
Bustin, Bustin, C2, thank you for the five.
Ah, Thrax, thank you for the 20.
Don't tell me what to do.
Oh, Valentine, thanks for the 20.
Hi, it's me, welcome back.
Okay, I'm out of here.
Bye!
Thank you guys, thank you.
Bye bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
I'm Mr. Obeezer, thank you for the five time.
Bloodlust, thank you for the 10.
nuclear that you wrote the 10.
Okay.